hello and welcome to this video playing
Danny man 10 okay come on I just want to
go D for him cuz laughs and what do I do
let's go for the slow Slav Bishop f5 on
Bishop g4 how the main moves here
yeah I think white now h3 is also i'm
not quite sure yeah this is I think one
of the main continuations I wonder if
phone hmm is it crazy to do this I think
this is actually possible in some
variations here the movie 5 is
irritating me a little bit maybe he can
go if I've somehow at the moment I think
g5 is hanging so probably not right now
but I have some vague some vague
recollection that there has been some
way of playing if I p.m. oh wow
okay it looks very slow for black
taking with the night hmm I got some I
have some weaknesses of Gaussian in a
pawn structure but f5 but I have well we
should 27 are you serious how are you
going to develop wow I don't don't don't
get that how is he going to develop he
ever with the night on g8 then I what's
a boss g6 of course that was also pretty
pretty tempting yeah of course I go see
5 here come on that looks funny so what
now Bishop c4 probably just developing I
have g6 also as an additional IDM and
queer NFC 6 is hanging here okay I think
as you can just retreat I have 96 and
other moves coming up the Queen on f3 is
looking at c-6 yeah
black resign yeah this is a way I was
about to say I really don't see a move
it's it's immensely bad it's immensely
bad this position how is he ever going
to untangle I don't see it he cannot
move any of his pieces and I'm always
looking at the c6 porn so let's have a
quick quick recap here yeah a g5 h5 is
mmm I don't know I don't believe in that
move after g5 he has to go back and what
have you accomplished there i mean if
you feel you need to react to g4 you
probably should go age 6 i guess in each
form maybe this is an idea i don't know
to take and have 94 available yeah I
don't know that opening 2 i'm just
making things up in each five so g5 and
and this is already pretty awful he has
to give up the center now I guess that's
all I thought Bishop c7 at least 22 half
97 now but I just doesn't look good also
remember this one yeah cuz I think
that's not play about this position the
engine is on plus two and now I'll plus
3 after that on plus 4 yeah he has to
move the engine light is g6 funny g6 and
now him I don't know I probably would
have given the check but I'm not sure
check just for for clarity's sake and
this kind of thing I'm attacking here
and i have rook e1 and Bishop takes is 6
coming so let's say rook c8 and their
weekly one and I don't see how he
prevents that it probably doesn't it's
funny Angelo plus 9 after 97 Bishop b6
yeah okay that wasn't that wasn't good
h5 was the start of a very bad bad plan
year for black okay thanks for watching